when hurricane maria hit puerto rico in
we all watched as a disaster played out
on our screens
at least 160 000 people were displaced
and nearly 3 000 people died
electricity was cut off to the entire
island and some neighborhoods didn't get
power back
for 11 months many of those watching
didn't know how to help
some donated to international ngos some
lobbied their elected officials
but as with so many crises so many of us
simply gave in
and felt helpless at the humanitarian
open street map team
also known as hot we did something
different we mobilized 6 000 volunteers
across the world
who mapped every home and every road in
puerto rico
and here you can see the maps those
volunteers made taking shape
responders then used those maps to
assess the state of buildings and roads
and to provide emergency funds wi-fi and
phone charging points
to people whose homes were damaged all
crises
including the covert 19 pandemic we're
living through right now
have devastating characteristics but
many of them have one thing in common
the people hit the hardest are often
literally not on the map
right now more than one billion people
live in places that are not mapped
if you look those places up online
you'll see nothing but a blank
and that blank isn't just a huge
statement of disrespect
to our fellow human beings it's an
injustice
causing very direct very real and very
avoidable human suffering
so what does not being on the digital
map actually look like
i live in peru and a few months ago some
community health workers asked us to
help them map
obviously where they were wasn't mapped
so to get there we asked the local mayor
to draw the route this is what he drew
this piece of paper was hard to follow
we didn't really know what these lines
were
he put some numbers on there that he
assured us for travel times
but as we were driving along these did
not correspond to our reality
but this isn't about me getting lost or
about shaming someone's bad drawing
skills
think how inefficient it is to manage a
team who need to work in this place
without a map to tell them where they
need to go then once they're in the
right village
how can they collect some data and
associate it to that place
those community health workers know that
needs in this region are high
particularly anemia and malnutrition
among children
they just don't know where those
children are or what is causing that
problem
they want to be able to locate the home
of every child under five but how can
they do that without a map
after a brief training we went out to
make a map and this is what those
community health workers produced
this map has everything you need to
navigate like the rivers and bridges
but it also has every local landmark the
school the football pitch the plaza
and i'm pleased to say that a few weeks
ago we got a call from those community
health workers
and they're using this map in their
response containing covert 19.
so you might be thinking why aren't
these places on commercial maps
in short mapping the most vulnerable
places in our world just
hasn't been a priority for for-profit
companies whose business models
typically rely on advertising and data
sales
this leaves out the poorest communities
and means that individual aid
organizations create maps for the small
areas that they're working in
in offline systems which rapidly become
out of date when a project
ends so what we have here is a lack of
easily shareable and easily updatable
data
but we also have a solution we met with
a tool called openstreetmap
which was founded in 2006 and is a free
open source tool which anyone can use to
map the world
just as anyone can read or edit an
article on wikipedia
anyone can use or edit the map in
openstreetmap and the resulting map is
public good
free and open for anyone to use creating
one map for all of us
it works in two phases buildings and
roads might not be on the map yet
but you can see them clearly in
satellite imagery volunteers working
anywhere in the world
turn satellite images into maps through
drawing the buildings and roads on top
of them
we call this a base map on average each
time a volunteer logs in
they map an area less than 10 kilometers
squared but add all those contributions
together and you come up entire cities
in just a couple of days
and second local mapping people living
and working in the places we're mapping
take that base map and colour it in for
example identifying
is this building a school or a hospital
those people add information you can't
see in a satellite image
we've found people able and eager to map
in even the most challenging situations
worldwide
and we've optimized the tools to work on
smartphones costing as little as 30
dollars
additionally the tools work offline so
people without regular access to cell
service can still contribute
adding things to the map as they go
about their daily lives and then
uploading when they get access
to cell service or wi-fi in 10 years
we've seen people from all walks of life
take part refugees have map broken water
points
rural women have added place names in
indigenous languages
and in doing so people become active
agents of change in their communities
since 2010 hot has engaged over 200 000
volunteers
who've mapped an area home to more than
150 million people in openstreetmap
those maps have been used by search and
rescue operations to free hundreds of
people trapped in collapsed buildings
after the 2010 haiti earthquake
they've been used to provide polio
vaccinations to children across all of
rural nigeria
and they've mapped the camps routes and
new homes
of more than 8 million refugees fleeing
south sudan
syria and venezuela we work with the
biggest humanitarian organizations in
the world to make sure these maps have
impact
the red cross med san san frontiere
unicef to name a few
and we currently have a queue of more
than 2 000 places needing to be mapped
so that's the story so far but wouldn't
it be great if these places were on the
map
before they were in crisis now we're
ready for a step change
over the past few years we've gained
access to global regularly updated
satellite imagery
machine learning and ai are helping
human mappers to work more efficiently
and worldwide more and more people are
willing and able to map
their communities over the next five
years
we'll engage one million volunteers who
will map an area home
to the one billion most vulnerable
people across 94 countries
to achieve this we need to do three
things
first we need to grow our community to
one million mappers
who will build a world where everyone
everywhere is represented
we'll set up a network of regional hubs
to train and support
those volunteers to map the vulnerable
places in their own countries
second we need to invest in technology
right now you can add something like a
building
or a local landmark to the map in just a
few seconds but
learning to map and mapping easily and
quickly on a mobile
can be a problem we need to invest in
technologies
to make mobile edits to the map possible
at a massive scale
and third we need to raise awareness aid
projects across the world
need to know that these maps are free
and available for them to use
and that they can request maps for the
areas that they're working in
for me this is one of the most wonderful
things about this project it isn't
really about hot or
any single organization it's about
creating a foundation on which
so many organizations will thrive
whatever we do
disasters and crises will still happen
and humanitarians will still respond to
them
development programs will continue but
without maps they'll lack critical
information about what to expect in a
community before they get there
with open free up-to-date maps those
programs will have more impact than they
would do otherwise
leading to a meaningful difference in
lives saved or improved
but it's so much more than that
it's 20 20 and 1 billion people in our
world are not
visible that's wrong this is a tool
through which every citizen of planet
earth can become known and
seen to literally be put on the map
my peers complain about being too over
connected so how can it be possible for
more than a billion people to remain
invisible
luckily this is a problem even the
laziest among us can help to solve
if you can swipe left or right you can
help
map this morning and influence
life-changing decisions this afternoon
frontline health workers and
humanitarians are literally waiting for
you
thank you